We have two very special guests joining the desk, Rossy.
I'm so excited. I love these two.
We were lucky enough to see them on Zoom last year,
in our very first year of this show,
these are original gangsters.
(audience laughing)
I know we said, hopefully,
we'll be able to see you here in the studio soon.
Well guess what, the dream is happening and it's real.
It's WWE All Star beauty entrepreneurs
and the co-hosts of "The Bella Podcast."
They share open and honest conversations
about motherhood and relationship.
Oh, here's a listen.
What is it, when you go wine tasting,
and -
Everything tastes good.
And then you take
And then do you buy
a bottle home.
all these bottles
and you come home and then you pop it open.
And you're like (retches) what is this?
It's because you and I said,
they let it breathe all day long.
I can't believe it.
(audience cheering)
Please welcome
back to the how, the Bella twins, Nikki and Brie Bella!
(everyone cheering)
Thank you for having us.
I liked how you called us the OGs.
Yeah!
We are OGs here now.
You kindly came on and graced us with your presence.
Aw.
Thank you. And super pregnant.
Weren't we? Super pregnant.
Yes!
Yeah.
That's right.
We've loved watching you guys over the years together.
Aw, thank you.
Thank you.
It's been an incredible journey.
I mean, since the womb, since we've entered this world,
we've had a blast, but just also being business partners
and growing and being entrepreneurs,
and what we've done as women
and breaking barrier is the WWE, we've just been so blessed.
And I think, as women and what we've done,
it's because we have each other.
So we were there to lift each other up when it was tough.
It's like my husband.
Yes.
It's like a marriage.
It is like a marriage.
I feel bad for our husbands.
(panel laughing)
It's true, they'll never have with you
what you have with each.
Yeah.
And they know that.
Which is good.
And that's wonderful.
Yeah.
As long as they
understand it right?
And now you've been WWE, are beauty moguls.
And now with the podcast, congratulations.
Thank you.
People are loving it.
I love the E show too.
(audience applauding)
I love the show.
The E show too,
of course, yes.
(audience applauding)
I always watch the show.
But what's so interesting, you do on your podcast,
is I love you have the guests
bring something with them each episode.
Can you tell us about that?
Yeah, so we wanted guests
to start bringing their favorite quote,
or something that means something to them.
'Cause we love ending the podcast
with something that's inspiring.
Something that our listeners can take away
and be like, you know, I needed that today.
And it's also kind of cool.
'Cause we're always like our guests,
when they tell you their quote.
You're kinda like, that's who you are as a person, so.
And they always give some intimate story to that.
Or why this motivates them, why this drives them.
And so you see a different side of people when they come on.
All right. Do you guys want to do some headlines with us?
Yeah.
We'd love to.
All right, Rossy, take it away.
(audience cheering)
Okay, but first,
we have a big wedding debate to settle.
The "Independent" reports, a groom asked if he was a jerk
for kicking his own brother-in-law out of his wedding,
but first you have to hear why he did it.
(woman laughing)
Because in addition
to making rude comments about the wedding,
at the wedding, during the ceremony itself,
the brother-in-law decided to start handing out invitations
for his own upcoming wedding.
(audience exclaiming)
Yeah. Okay.
So he said, you're out of here. What do you all think?
'Cause there was a big debate online.
Do you think this crossed the line, or was the groom a jerk?
So, I'll say definitely rude,
but I think it's a little harsh
to kick your brother-in-law, out of the wedding.
What? Okay, I'd be like, au revoir.
Bye bye.
(audience laughing)
Really?
If you started
dissing my wedding ,at my wedding
and then handing invitations out,
I'd be like, Brie, pack your bags, go to your hotel room.
I'll catch you tomorrow. For sure.
I have to say I'm with Nikki
on this one.
Yay.
I mean, what a jerk move.
(audience laughing)
This guy can just
take a big fat hike.
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
(hands slapping)
Yeah.
Interesting.
I'm planning my wedding right now and I'll tell you,
if you come to my wedding and dis it to my face,
at least have the decency to talk about me behind my back.
Okay?
(people laughing)
Like a normal human being.
You are out of my wedding.
Outta here!
I agree.
Will you take our next headline, please ladies.
Oh yes we'd love to.
Alright, so next we got a workout that's trending,
that we absolutely love.
"Real Simple" reports, if you wanna get some good cardio in,
try jumping rope.
Ooh.
Woo!
It gets the blood pumping quick and fitness pros say,
if you go back to the activities you love as a kid,
it can increase your enjoyment in working out as an adult.
Yes, it works on so many muscle groups at once.
It hits calves, core, arms, shoulders, upper back.
Ross and Drew, wanna try it with us?
Um.
Oh.
Wait a minutes, is it true that you guys do this?
We do it with our trainer. It's a good warmup, so.
You can burn so many calories jumping rope
and have a lot of fun.
And it can make you smile really quick.
Okay, ladies, you know when we're kids
and we jumped rope, why is it so different now?
(audience laughing)
(Ross laughing)
Things start to fall to the ground
and now we have to really lift them up.
(audience laughing)
We got jump ropes
right here, you wanna try?
Let's do it.
(audience cheering)
Come over here.
I'm gonna do it here.
Had to pull up my pants, be careful on these heels.
Yes.
This is a bad idea.
Oh, wow.
Alright.
You know what.
I don't know
how I feel about this, okay.
Any tips?
High and fast.
'Cause sometimes slow you trip.
Yeah, but you can kinda-
(audience laughing)
There we go.
Oh smart, smart, yeah.
(people laughing)
(audience applauding)
I love it.
(audience cheering)
Do you do that on purpose or is that a total accident?
That is a total accident.
(people laughing)
I was like, oh well, here we go.
Okay.
I feel like you can kind of though do the step first,
before the two step.
Yeah, do that one, show me.
Yeah you're right, the step.
(audience laughing)
Okay.
Ready?
You know like.
(ropes whipping)
There you go.
Oh, oh!
(audience cheering)
Drew!
Oh my!
(upbeat music)
Oh my God, we were doing it!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
That was really encouraging to know that I could-
You still got it!
You can do it!
So you still want to keep going, right?
(Drew panting)
Bloods pumping, flowing.
It's not easy, but it's doable.
(people laughing)
Brie and Nikki Bella, Brie and Nikki, love you guys so much.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
It means so much.
For showing up today
in person.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Thank you Nikki and Brie,
get the "The Bellas Podcast" on SiriusXM Stitcher
and we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)